hallo klicks um halo kraftklub meine
frage an euch werde wie seid ihr auf die
idee mit dem body painting beim
bundesvision song contest gekommen und
wie fühlt sich so eine komplett rasiert
und
dann noch eine frage an felix als bad
boy hast du gemerkt dass du prinz pi
hast jetzt bist du ja auf einem auf dem
remix von offen davon von der kespa
szene mit ihm zusammen drauf
wir sind das da das verhältnis aktuell
so das haben meine fragen ich hoffe ich
eine antwort und
ich freue mich auf die tour
das mit dem body painting war so
dass er
eigentlich wäre haben wir haben letztes
jahr haben wir das aber wir das mal
angeschaut mit kumpels und haben gesagt
wenn wir da mal auftreten sollten das
spiel wir nackt und die alle macht ihr
nicht natürlich war ich etwas betrunken
ein jahr später war es soweit und die
haben natürlich nicht vergessen und dann
sollten wir das machen dachte mir aber
auch nackt werken wie doch irgendwie
blöd und da haben wir in einem prospekt
wurden sport prospekt autotuning also
frauen drauf und die waren halt auch
nackt aber mit bodypainting kann diese
rennfahrer outfits
aufgemalten da dachten wir das ist
das machen wir auch das ist cool und das
vielleicht haben wir die wandels
rasieren ja das teil zwei der ersten
frage bewusst zeit komplett rasieren
also beide
und halt nach oben popo auch den
genitalbereich ja das hätte aber gar
nicht möglich machen müssen wir die
schlüpfer anhalt in einer gesagt kinder
es waren vorher shoppen im schlecker
oder so was muss da dam rasierer gold
und
dachten dass es das andere rasierer sind
die halt cooler sind aber das ist
wahrscheinlich die
rasierklingen männer rasierer und da ist
man halt sie hatten hotelzimmer und
jeder sachsen-anhalt können alle zwei
stunden in der dusche hat geschwitzt und
da wir uns dann daher komplett rasiert
und gestimmt also dass ich
das jetzt hinter der kamera hat sich
keine ahnung 20 mal an den beinen
geschnitten und alt das ganze bett folge
blutet und das tier war das mädchen mit
der periode im hotel ist aber noch
nichts
teil 2 er frei ist
das verhältnis prinz pi ist auf jeden
fall gut der ist ja auch gleiche buch
agentur wie wir und
treffen uns immer mal und da ist alles
cool das heißt so
weil ich ja war ja auch 16 wo ich den
song gemacht hat oder so
das ist ja auch alles wieder ins lot
gebracht ja und dann der song ist ein
remix und
wo prinz pi drauf ist walter hat gar
keine rolle gespielt ob das früher mal
gedicht oder so sind alle alle cool mit
nenner